Okay.
It is time for hatred mail.
Quick reminder.
What are we talking about when we talk about
Patriot mail?
Brace yourselves for the only information
that can successfully penetrate a 10 foil
hats.
Hey tree.
It may fail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because freedom,
this makes hatred mail actually is is a perfect
segue into something I was, I've been meaning
to discuss with you.
Let's take a listen to it.
David Pakman Bay
[inaudible].
This new beta defeatist mentality you developed
is wide.
Dems always lose.
Always great commentary from the beta males
of Pacman.
Cute button, meaningless.
We congratulate soy boy Pacman on the subscriber
counts.
It is now higher than his sperm count.
He shows that even a beta male can be amazing.
I was thinking how quickly these memes come
in and out of favor.
About a year ago, this whole beta male versus
alpha male thing was huge.
It was everywhere online.
Now it seems to only be satirical.
It's kind of a joke.
Soy boys sort of a similar thing and by the
way, yes, the subscriber account is climbing.
My goal is for us to reach 800,000 YouTube
subscribers by my birthday.
On February 2nd so here's the math of it.
I looked at the math this morning as of this
recording, we are 11 days from my birthday
now, that's 11 days from the start of February
2nd you know there's this full 24 hour period
all the way up until midnight on February
3rd but let's ignore that for now.
We're 11 days from the start of my birthday.
As of right now, we are 3,511 subscribers
away from 800,000 so in order to get to 800,000
subscribers by my birthday, we need to net
gain 319 subscribers a day.
That's not unreasonable because on a good
day, like for example, the first day of the
Trump impeachment, a trial when we had a livestream
and we had a bunch of videos that did well,
we had a net gain of a thousand subscribers.
Now on a bad day, for example, like on a weekend
when things are slower on YouTube, sometimes
we only gain a hundred subscribers.
Every once in a while, YouTube will close
down inactive accounts.
And when they do that, we lose subscribers
as those accounts are purged.
So it's doable.
It'll probably be a close call.
So help us, it's a way to send a middle finger
salute to the hatreds youtube.com/the David
Pakman show, hit subscribe.
800,000 is the goal.
By February 2nd